you seem to be smiling a little bigger
Tonight George I wonder why is that I'm
thinking because Brad Pitt finally
admitted to the world yes who are the
most handsome men in the world past and
present well I got a name that George
Clooney
it's time time he finally admitted that
that I'm the guy
[Music]
I think maybe you're beaming a little
bit tonight because you just celebrated
your eighth wedding anniversary with
your beautiful wife pretty amazing yeah
what makes it's so special for the two
of you we just feel really lucky we're
having a really wonderful time now we
got two five-year-old kids running
around too and speaking all sorts of
languages that we don't speak is an
issue how did you celebrate for your
beautiful girl we went to one of our
favorite New York restaurants yes and we
had a lovely dinner quiet dinner
Amal was giving us 1920s flapper Vibes
in a custom Versace gown dripping
chandelier beads I made the dress myself
yeah right
I'm afraid I'm leaving a trail behind me
it's okay what a trail it is the super
Glam couple we're in Manhattan launching
the Clooney foundation's Albee Awards to
bring attention to corruption and
Injustice through the foundation we're
now in more than 40 countries and it's
just been amazing to see the response
that we've gotten there is a lot of
power in in their involvement Hollywood
stepped up to support Julia Roberts and
Burberry Jody Turner Smith went sheer
Meryl Streep was also an all black and
Gayle King who crashed our Drew
Barrymore interview Rachel you know Drew
and I had a girls night out oh really
Styles and now we're here
[Music]
oh and there was this many ER reunion
Juliana Margulies says she's not
surprised by George's commitment the
second he said years ago if the cameras
are going to follow me I may as well go
to Sudan and make a difference and
China's Spotlight I thought that's his
crowning moment and it's defined his
life since then
I can't wait for the morning show to
come out I know you guys are currently
I'm working tomorrow actually here in
New York oh I shouldn't say that
and a little more news about a TV star
we love Jonathan Bailey's been casting
Wicked what did you make of it when you
were I screamed I'm so proud of him and
he so deserves that he's amazing
[Music]